here's what would happen if an iced  tsunami hit the United States  the wall of ice formed by an ice tsunami  could be 30 to 40 feet high it's  forceful enough to move huge ice  Boulders and even break steel reinforced  concrete  fortunately unless you lived somewhere  on the coast of New York State like  Montauk East Hampton or Long Beach the  risk of being impacted by an ice tsunami  would be low if you lived near Lake Erie  you might actually remember a nice  tsunami in 2019 this weather event  occurred with winds up to 113 kilometers  per hour or in Lakme Lac near Onamia  Minnesota an ice tsunami wiped out two  dozen two-story buildings luckily no one  was injured unless you lived in an area  of high coastal flooding you'd probably  be okay so